memorial day is memorial day it is a
time to honor the men and women who have
given their lives
fighting for weekends like this bianca
holmen live right now at woodlong
cemetery near downtown
for its annual memorial day program
bianca
yes here at the cemetery there is a flag
at each site
for soldiers who died serving their
country remembering those who left to
fight for freedom
but did not return home making the
ultimate sacrifice
feelings of gratitude and love but also
a time
to mourn the memorial day program
honored heroes who gave their all
for their fellow comrades and country
it's been two years since the program
was held in person so there were many
families
veterans and active duty personnel here
we spoke with an army reservist who
named his son after a peer who died in
combat
he dedicates this day to him
it wasn't for nothing we honor you every
day matthew
matt morris i love you and i would give
my life for yours
all of us together need to say today is
the beginning of my giving back to this
country
and being purposeful in what i do and
being accepting and making sure
i am a positive force in this city in
this county in this state and in this
nation
it's also a time to recognize gold star
families children
spouses and parents of those who lost
their lives
during service now at three this
afternoon people are asked to take a
pause
for memorial day to remember those who
made the ultimate sacrifice
bianca holman 8 news now bianca thank
you very much
also later today memorial day ceremonies
will be held at the southern nevada
veterans memorial cemetery down in
boulder city
that event starts at one in about an
hour or so down in
again boulder city if you plan to go to
that event just make sure you wear a
mask
and respect social distancing guidelines